talking about the main character from
turning red watching trash taste I
actually had my first I guess celebrity
moment that I haven't uh that I haven't
I don't think I've talked about in trash
the first clout movement yeah my first
Cloud real Cloud moment yeah no where
it's it's it was weird right because of
course it was in LA meeting a celebrity
of course of course yeah people talk
about it all the time yeah it happened
for me once actually and
it's so weird because being on trash
days and talking about guys if you see
me on the street don't be afraid to say
hi I'm not gonna buy you know just come
say hi take a picture I'll sign
something whatever I don't care you know
I've said we've said that so many times
on trash taste yeah but then when it
happened to me on the other side in real
life I I became everything that I warned
against right so me and Sydney were
having lunch in this Cafe in La
um and it was like a Mexican restaurant
or something we were just having like a
quick lunch and a beer there
um and then
Sydney was like is that is that who I
think it is and I turn around I'm like
who are you talking about and she points
to like a table right in the corner yeah
right and she's like I think that's the
waitress from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia which if you haven't
watched Always Sunny in Philadelphia
it's like a sitcom it's one of mine and
Sydney's like favorite sitcoms of all
time
um and there's a character in there
that's not one of the main characters
but kind of like a side character that's
reoccurring and her name's the waitress
and I was like and she points to her and
I'm like [ __ ] that is that is the
waitress yeah
and I'm like I'm Sydney and and we both
want to take a picture we both want to
say hi and take a picture and I'm like
no Sydney we're not we're not doing it
we're not doing Sydney don't don't do
this don't do this it's like I need my
cloud yeah I need my dose of clouds I
can't I need some clouds from lack of
clouds and like for the first time I I
got it I I understood that feeling now
of just you can't just go up yeah you
can't just go up because I'm like no we
can't go up there I mean if it's in a
restaurant it's a lot more Awkward yeah
yeah obviously and and also they were
sitting right in the corner as well and
me my my brain I've been I was like I've
been here before if I'm sitting in the
corner I don't want to be noticed and
she was sitting in the corner table on
the corner of the corner table so I'm
like no I can't do it I can't go up
though I can't I can't go up there but
luckily Sydney being the [ __ ] Giga
Chad being like gone I'll do it I'll
[ __ ] do it step aside herbivore I
will do it I will do it and like Sydney
no Cindy stop don't do it and then she
walks up and she says yeah can I get a
picture and of course it was it was
exactly that it was everything that I
said would happen which was of course
she was more than happy she was like
very excited to take a picture and I'm
just like damn I feel like such an ass
no I feel like such an idiot right now I
I had that exact same thing at the con
in Miami right except like you'd think
that because you're at a convention it
would be easier than say like a
restaurant setting right because you
know every like famous person who's
there is there to meet people right yeah
so it's like already you know
pre-established right but Conor and I
were in The Green Room right all right
which is like the one part of the con
for guests uh yeah you know for guests
of the con to just like chill out you
know just like kind of you know have a
little bit of peace and quiet and
privacy and stuff right there right yeah
you know because that's how I feel when
I go into a green room
um but so I feel that's the worst place
to be able to go up to someone right in
my head right but then the exact same
thing he was sitting in the corner just
like chilling on his phone and I'm like
I'm like I think that's Adam Savage from
MythBusters
oh and I was just like that's definitely
and I checked the website just to make
sure I was like one of those people I'm
like or is it just the lookalike I don't
know so I went on and I'm like oh that's
Adam from Mythbusters and I was just
like
I remember I turned to Conor I was like
I have to say hi I was like go ahead
yeah I consciously just go ahead I'm
like yeah but and I was second guessing
I was just like yeah but he's like
chilling in the corner I don't know if
he wants I don't know if he like you
know wants to be left alone and [ __ ]
like that and then it wasn't until my
handler was like just [ __ ] God I was
like oh okay so then I went up to him
yeah because you know I think it's
because we're not used to being as you
said we're not used to being on the
other side of that yeah because you know
like you don't often run into
celebrities in your daily life right
yeah
um and and so it's like as I was walking
up to him I was just imagining every
worst possibility that could happen
right of like oh what if he's an [ __ ]
what if he just like turns me away what
if he just like denies a photo blah blah
of course that didn't happen he was the
nicest [ __ ] person ever and he was
just like yeah let's take a photo and
like stood up and everything and it was
like five second interaction but I'm
like yeah
all right because like it taught me so
much because just just meeting I believe
her name is Mary Elizabeth Gwen I think
that's her name I'm the waitress the
waitress just just meeting her and be
able to take a picture bro that that
just made our day honestly oh yeah
absolutely even just that short
interaction of just like damn I've seen
you so much and you've had like
indirectly just such a big effect such a
such a big effect on a lot of our
evenings damn that felt that felt good
it literally I was like because because
I've I've heard fans say damn just
meeting just meeting me made made that
day or whatever I'm like I'm not don't
please don't say that yeah
I am not that good like but like me just
being able to take a picture and
[ __ ] yourself going up to them
taking the picture I'm like I I get it
now guys I get it
for me I don't know like I don't really
want to take pictures with uh like
celebrities or anything it doesn't do
anything for me yeah I mean most of the
time it doesn't for me as well the only
reason this mattered to us was because
Always Sunny the weird like we'd like
watch all of the seasons
five ten I I like I grew up with
MythBusters so it's like one of my
favorite is a show or something change
your mind but for me it's like even if I
got a picture with them I'm like all
right well I mean I would have preferred
to have an organic conversation at some
point but obviously you can't force that
yeah yeah so it's to me it's like you
don't want to be that guy right yeah
yeah I mean I don't like I don't know I
just don't I don't really get star
struck by anyone as well like I just
kind of like I'm like if I happen to
talk to someone who did something I've
watched that's really [ __ ] cool and
that's awesome but if I don't I I'm
still gonna live my life not exactly
like there is some like I'm not like I
wouldn't be this like every celebrity if
I if I meet like [ __ ] Leonardo
DiCaprio I'd be like that's really cool
it's Leonardo DiCaprio but I wouldn't be
like you know he hasn't had a massive
effect in my life but I'd still be
shooting myself I'd be shooting myself
well like I wouldn't but like it would
be different if I had met something like
I'm trying to think Quentin Tarantino
grew up with this grew up with his films
[ __ ] respect the [ __ ] out of him if I
got a chance to meet him that's like one
person off the top of my head I would
actually be Starstruck about yeah yeah
because he's uh he's done a lot he's
probably trying to [ __ ] off as well
[Music]
I'll give you an extra one and he goes
somewhere and then tells them to [ __ ]
off yeah that's the kind of energy he
gives you because every time I see just
a Quentin Tarantino interview I'm like
oh Quentin Tarantino is just a Quentin
Tarantino character in a Quentin
Tarantino movie you know like it's he
talks exactly like one of the characters
you know any of the characters he would
write and it's just God what I would
give just well that's why he's in his
own movies a lot of the time because he
doesn't have to act that's just him yeah
exactly right but yeah like is there
anyone you would you think you'd be
Starstruck about if you ever met them in
real life uh I mean Adam isn't the only
one I've been Starstruck by the the the
first person I ever felt like that
feeling of StarStruck which I'm probably
talked about uh was um I met Oba
tatakishi yeah at a con he's the guy who
uh Drew Death Note oh yeah um yeah he
was at a con randomly and uh that was
the one time
uh in Canada yeah he was just he was he
was he was a guest that I think it'll
talk with someone one of the years where
I was a guest at and I was really well I
think I've told this story but like
basically we went to the opening
ceremony because we would guess and then
they were like uh you know introducing
each of the guests well it was a bunch
of voice actors couple YouTubers stuff
like that and then they were like uh now
for on for the the Japanese guests and
then they'd list off a couple of people
and they were like and finally we have
the uh one of the creators of death note
or what's a takushi and he just didn't
stand up yeah and so I so everyone in
that room thought oh he's just not there
right he just didn't show up to the
meeting whatever I was just like maybe
I'll see him a little marriage you can't
understand English yeah yeah that was
like I was like maybe I'll see him you
know but I wasn't thinking like oh I'll
get to meet him and whatever maybe I'll
see him in a distance you know while I'm
walking through the corn or whatever
which is so cool whatever and then as
we're walking out of the opening
ceremony uh Aki was just like you should
turn around right now and literally I
think this distance away it was just
about to talk to you it's just like
walking right behind me it's like the
scene from Death Note yeah it was it was
it was just it was doing the L stare at
me
and uh and I just turned around and that
Split Second I just felt like oh I want
to say hi to him so bad and try and get
a photo and that would have been the
perfect opportunity but I chickened out
and now you now you experience and that
was the moment where I was like oh my
God this is what being Starstruck is
yeah you're usually gonna turn around oh
they're hunting this I mean they
probably would have started to be like
oh yeah would have right I could I could
have so easily just started talking in
Japanese instant Icebreaker yeah but
that I I just saw him and I'm like holy
[ __ ] that's all about the Target shoes
and then I just couldn't talk to him
yeah and and that's that was the moment
where I was like oh I get it I get it
why now some people are like this with
with you know people they admire it's
because I I just experience that